Here's our factored answer. Great work if you got that one correct. To divide a
rational expression, we multiply by the recripricol. So, we change division to
multiplication and flip the second fraction over. We can use factoring patterns
to find the factors of this numerator and. And denominator. This is a difference
of squares. So we have x plus 3 times x minus 3. Our denominator, however, is a
perfect square trinomial. So we'll have x minus 3 times x minus 3. We find
factors of negative 6 that sum to negative 5. Those factors are negative 6 and
positive 1. We use factoring by grouping to get 2x plus 1 times x minus 3. For
our denominator, we want to find factors of negative 36. That sum to negative 5.
Those factors are negative 9 and positive 4. After factoring, we get 3x plus 2,
times, 2x minus 3. Now we're ready to simplify our factors. This x minus 3
divided by x minus 3 equals 1. And look at that, there's another x minus 3,
divided by x minus Is 3. Those will also equal 1. And our remaining factors are
x plus 3 and 2x plus 1 for the numerator, and 3x plus 2 times 2x minus 3 in our
denominator.